dun-dun-dun already it is time for the
third and final opportunity to make this
blog look awesome feel free to use the
blog that you've been working on or if
you want to fresh start you can download
a clean version in the downloadable
section and just like before I'm going
to give you some mandatory changes and
some optional changes for the blog as
you setup in the first iteration of the
blog the images right now are basically
just big enough so they look good on
large high DPI displays the good news is
that you're guaranteed to deliver high
quality images to everyone but the bad
news is that these images are probably
too big for most devices there's also
the added issue of artwork in that when
the viewport is small users are seeing a
wide image and they may miss some of the
most important elements like for
instance here on a phone with a wide
image of the horses they just look like
dots you can't really make out any
detail enter the picture element for
this part of the project I want you to
use the picture element to deliver
different images based on viewport
widths and for some images like the
horses I want you to display a different
crop of the image based on browser width
so if the window gets small crop it in
so we can actually see the horses it
usually makes sense to show tighter and
tighter crops of an image as the browser
gets smaller and remember you can use
the source set attribute to change which
images displayed based on device pixel
ratio take advantage of this in the
solution you'll see me set breakpoints
at 500 and 750 pixels for my picture
elements I'll also set up images for 1x
and 2x displays when the browser is
larger than 750 pixels and just like the
first time you worked on the project
I'm giving you a boilerplate grunt file
to help you get started and once you're
delivering fully responsive images with
the picture element make sure to add
some descriptive alt tags if the images
need them as an optional challenge you
can make this blog look a little bit
nicer in the solution you'll see me use
the section tag to separate pieces of
content I'll add a new font from google
fonts as well and there might be a few
other aesthetic changes to the text so
once you've used the picture tag with
source set to deliver
is based on different browser widths and
display densities and you've added alt
attributes to all of your images a code
will appear on the screen type that code
in here to continue but hey don't forget
this is your baby and this is an art so
try a new font and maybe style the text
just a little bit better